you
I'm gonna say that Carlson has entered
this and I'm going to guess that this is
Carlson
now I'm gonna say that dr. Chunkin Stein
is actually Carlson here a hundred and
fifty are now entered as soon as the
tournament begins triple zeros foam
penguin GM is going to be playing some
color against car wanna let the games
begin
I agree in five seconds all right we're
hopping over let's see what the penguin
has
against Cara wanna penguin playing from
his tablet
I believe Oh No okay there we go okay
not their first time playing game number
eight I like blacks position I must say
having this strong pawn in the center a
nice jumping point in the center 97
it's the idea here I wants to get
rolling in the center what was that
about
oh he just trapped his own Bishop with
g3 the bishop was short on squares
penguin is up a piece and penguin will
convert this one is my is my bet two
pawns for the piece Swanson piece
exchanges how to get this rook activated
Queen keeps pressure here and you could
take that pawn though looking for some
sacrifices on g3 picks up upon this
point is defended Queens unprotected
there's no Bishop move Black has to be
very careful of f7
mashing through you could you could give
up this pawn if the Queen is still
defending g7 he's going to fall and the
Queen is there defending f7 rook is
entering now just a consolidating move
the Queen is defending our base points
rook up and over
pieces are defended mate threat on e1o
penguin oh that's tough man
oh he just got mated men the old matin -
you forgot f7 was hit pressure let's
jump into another one
in fact let's stick on mud Pro for a
couple of games
International Master battle currently
let's see how this one plays out
what Pro versus upper don't know what
opening this one was I like the black
queen position and was liking the knight
position might try some kind of
undermining idea get the knight to this
square even if it costs upon rook is
gonna play soon he needs to find a new
home the King side is where the action
is hmm I don't know about the knight
post can do a knight comparison he's
kind of clumsy the Black Knight
no Queen exchange and then the knight
would get to the f5 square
now the attention is on the queenside
with the Queen's off I prefer black here
because the King position is going to be
an issue like for as long as the rook
stays on in bullet chests there's all
these annoying checks and the King
always has to kind of guess whereas this
structure here is very nice though at
the moment Knight takes c6 is a threat
little pin aroni
so black king is getting flushed away
look at how close these guys are with
the clock just gonna have a repetition a
little repetition there yeah that one's
a repetition draw on board oh let's see
one more by mud Pro
who's he going to get paired up against
Elda 64
you will will switch over to some other
player after this game we'll see the see
what the top page is looking like killer
bishops
queen h5 combined with the
you know there's already attacked at
Queen takes or even Queen h5
straightaway or Bishop takes h7 light is
up upon make sure you have your base
points covered wonder how penguin is
feeling after that first game I'm sure
he'll recover but
so close might have something similar
that's right you could scoop up the pond
converts this this is the correct kind
of shelter that you want King on g2
everything is defended no with that
undermining move
pressure on f7 could escort this pawn a
little bit more
it's a pawn race again black is down
upon but their pawn is further advanced
and you're going to be picking up this
guy so black is in the driver's seat
here
perpetual checks though
you know this should be some type of
Perpetual now that there's no Jeep on
but you never know
this Queen does a good job controlling
the sum squares some checking squares
it's down to 12 seconds teamwipe Oh
Queen exchange and now this pond is
gonna run okay they're gonna continue to
play let's jump over to let's see home
let's let's let's see about this drunken
Stein who currently has three wins in a
row
let's see about this doctor drunken
Stein this is the account that I said
maybe Carlsen so let's see if we could
figure out if this is Carlsen just by
the just by the skill the name doesn't
tell us anything
okay
huh f5 right around the corner
c3 needs to be covered keep the Knights
on 95 this is the I like the Knights
better for wipe do a knight comparison
there's a little bit of space with the
pawn on e5 a battle over the G file now
to negate the knight from coming into g4
and they just jumped in anyhow ah
there's a pin pawn takes pawn takes and
then there's an issue with knight on f3
little regrouping
you know it's a night yeah well look at
the time ARCA is so fast nine seconds up
tonight isn't a pin his queen is very
active the white whites night I was
saying earlier is better than the black
night but right now blacks Queen is far
better than the white queen black queen
is in whites house very difficult to
defend this okay one rook is off both
rooks are off white is up upon and
threatening to invade interesting move
you have to throw the knight in the
corner defend against g6 seven point
seven seconds this night is an excellent
defender against checks one pawn is gone
this one's gonna fall as well oh there
goes the night can he convert four point
seven White's gonna be able to do it I'm
gonna check and he's gonna advance four
point two is plenty of time
two seconds one second why was there
such a delay there uh he pulled off the
me unbelievable
let's track this guy this guy let's
track this guy okay doctor drunken Stein
very suspicious very suspicious bloody
no auto queen oh you know what that
might have been the thing
yeah very someone in the chat was just
saying no auto queen
and open so okay here we go another game
by dr. drunken Stein
crazy g5 move I've had a veneer play
this against me
it's g5 move let's see how the GM
handles it oh this is a pretty annoying
pawn where's where's white gonna put
their king
queenside ideally King safety rook
activity gonna be greedy what's that
move about oh man
doctor drunken stomach just trapped mate
ouch brutal men Queen takes Knight check
with the fork and then me
Wow now in stings
human drunken Stein is human we're still
gonna watch a couple more at least wow
that one caught me and
clearly dr. Chunkin Stein by surprise
the O matin one
brutal
okay that right there is a key square so
is that so is this one getting a night
both of these squares that would be nice
black has some space is not interested
in taking out the bishop or is he he
wants another night in there pressure on
c3 at this stage
one pond is down who's this player more
grin down upon and just looking to pick
up another one
much safer King team black how do you
get out of this pin it's not fun to have
to devote your Queen to the defense and
you can't really get out of the pin so
easily because of night to f2 that'll be
a killer fork and that's a slick move
Queen takes rook and then the Falls and
then the rook falls I just resigned here
a little fork
not sure why it's a I wanna I want to
stay right here on drunken Stein's
channel okay ah per dr. drunk tan doctor
the doctor of the doc we're just gonna
calm the doc the doc oh you know what
I've seen I've seen Carlson do this
before okay Kyle out see no light square
bishop
space for white better bishop and
slightly better development for Team
white their check okay Queen was hitting
both the night end f7
a little reposition with the night get
the night into f5 not sure what queen
the f5 is doing
kind of like this little reposition
earlier it's just playing on the
queenside now rook takes pawn as a
threat they're safer Square for the King
King h3 now he's just breaking things
down who cares about the pawn I want to
break things open here the night will be
a very good defender in case the rooks
try to enter ya White's kind of
overloading here on the Queen side if
there isn't any action breaking through
on g3 this is going to be a problem
this Knight could go in here before a
check as pawn is pinned 20 seconds of
piece piling up on the pin Knight takes
opens up the Queen to g3 giving up the
exchange but this Knight is enormous
Queen check another check and the queen
is gone can you take and then just give
some checks over here this is what black
is gonna try their safe haven in the
corner and now we have a matin one
threat black resigns Wow okay well
currently in first we have mini air toy
walk just a quick glance here page two
what's on let's have a look at John
Ludvig hammer point
let's see how he's doing we'll watch one
of his games and one righteth right from
the beginning where is penguin that's a
good that's a good question
we'll see I'm sure he'll be on the front
page soon enough if he's not already so
let's see what hammer has up his sleeve
here isn't this like a similar structure
to what the doc was just playing I have
some kind of cave mannish idea employed
in this game again Queen takes the rook
is hanging something might happen on h4
there are a few pieces converging there
opposite sides castling
five hang on h3 there was a main threat
on g3 things are happening changing so
fast King needs to get out of this
diagonal white at this point I'd really
want
what to happen Queens off so that these
pawns find it easier to run right now
you kind of want to keep them back home
shelter against the Queen checks mate
threat
need a flight square
if there's a rook check so some square
for the King and now we're gonna have
mate Oh white missed mate there oh and
got mated Oh white had an opportunity
for mate there instead of Queen here
just go right down mmm okay let's see
another one right from the top
hammer against the warning to GM's going
at it the warning finished fifth
went away from the first title arena
with some cash
killer a killer move Knight takes d4
hitting the Queen ready to take the
Queen width check
that's a Connor
the knight is trapped though yeah blacks
gonna be able to do something as soon as
the knight moves the Queen could enter
he's just giving some material back he's
only up a pawn now hmm wasn't there a
better way forward still better for Team
black but I something was missed they're
gonna go hunting down the pond also a
lead on the clock for the warning his
pawn Falls opposite color bishops but
this guy goes into pac-man mode now you
know let's see if we could pull this one
off hmm
I think I think why can't hold this one
also doesn't have their correct color
Bishop yeah this one should be a draw
this one Mike oh the 50 move rule
actually let's see or they're just gonna
have a route some repetition of position
why should be able to hold this one
Bishop sacrifices itself for this pawn
and the King goes in the corner
right now Bishop takes fun still has an
opportunity to take the phone this is
the pond the bishop wants to sack itself
for or even once it gets here
White's ready to sacrifice 13 seconds
each there goes the Queen King takes and
straight away it's stalemate all right
let's jump over to a different game oh
let's see about somebody else again
towards the very end we're definitely
gonna stay up top how about let's sneak
in a game let's see how Casey's let's
see how Casey is doing a game or two and
then we're gonna jump over to something
else this game and one more and we'll
see some other game time edge is the
first thing I'm noting about this one
white is down upon and White's gonna get
some material back though Queen is
defended let's see how I converts this
the bishop is stopping castling
let's see the conversion
you
that's a little bit annoying rook is
getting active
you could try for this kind of stuff
you're shooting for this and me
Oh even better upon me nice alright
let's see one more right from the top by
KC one more by KC let's do it
what position is he in he's in 21st
right now he's paired up against the
warning the warning was playing just
moments ago against hammer time
alright this pawn has gone into pac-man
mode
who cares about recapturing
some attack clearing the way
both bishops are pointing at each
other's kings in this position and now a
new piece is brought to life here and
back the bishop up some kind of rook up
and over main threat dark square
weaknesses can you get the bishop here
doesn't appear like you can pull that
off darks where bishops are going to be
exchanged
the oldrover look up and over you could
take the bishop no rookie ch4 and then
f5 have the Queen defend h7 y a more
direct stuff hmm
okay there's not going to be an attack
against the black King now black just
gave up some material you can't push
because of capture and then you get made
itself light square first drop the
bishop back make sure the pawn doesn't
go any further 28 seconds 14 black call
it even on the clock 26 each blue rook
here that's a threat a big one he's
going into the think tank ah there goes
the Queen really black didn't want the
Queen in that position he wants pigs he
wants some pigs look at the clock though
it's not looking good for team black and
a pin or owning yeah there's the queen
is kind of out of play she's on a good
square but not combined with anything
else Casey went down in that one let's
have a look at doctor drunken Stein
again there we go
all right dr. Minear
Munir is the one who gave mate last time
okay we have a draw there I mean yours
having a good results for sure that's
okay op er okay doctor and the doctor is
in first place pair it up with the
number 8 guy op er okay
how to solve the bishop
this game I feel could just end any
moment but these the bishops and knight
jumping into e5 they break the pin there
should be seven there's some weaknesses
here ninety-five could hunt down the
bishop pair this Knight is pretty good
though maybe valuing the the knight far
better than the bishop in this position
kind of take him out whenever you want
or just flush him back so he's strictly
defensive to be careful of these
sacrifices the bishop is actually pretty
good defender their flight's square with
h3 tension is going to turn towards the
queen side with the majority three
versus two tough to get these guys
rolling though with the nice grip over
the dark squares better Bishop for Team
black I like blacks position taking with
the wow what just happened there
something changed so fast I blinked I
blinked and then the bishops were gone
and now this pawn is pushing through oh
my goodness in black resigned a black
resigned well well done good commentary
on that game you said black resigned
that's what I got away from that oh boy
all right let's stay on the dock
let's stay on the dock Oh guerilla
battle of the GMS but which one is the
super GM are they both super GM's
let's see alright what opening is this
once I get to what opening it is it'll
be the it'll be the end game
all right some Queens gambit declined
huh
Carlsbad structure a little grip over e
5e for is in their isolated pawn
weakened King position no Shack you have
to negate it with the bishop and in the
end you're gonna have a fork
not so fast okay now if you took with
the knight there's an in-betweener on d4
white is up the exchange after all of
them and this Bishop is in a pickle how
do you deal with this even sacrificed
the Queen know and just liquidating
giving some material back or is that
even going on we have another resigner
there
why twins
let's I need to stay right here on this
one 38 is in first 32 32 31 another game
still tracking the top guy doctor
drunken Stein
in exchange French defense
all right let's let's see what black
pulls off here you can't queenside
castle just yet
some exchanges are good for black here
a little less space for black with this
pawn presence that'd be funny castles
Queen takes h2 and this is this is
winning winning a piece here the knight
and the rook are hit and just like that
I was a fast one the thirty second game
not even alright number one guy versus
number six toy Hawk Geum versus fm
caro-kann advance
Black's going for the bad
good bishop exchange this is a trap well
you could go here bishop they're here
and the bishop is a little bit
uncomfortable it's difficult to keep the
Queen defending the bishop
black doesn't bite for the f2 point
space the night move just to get the
f-pawn rolling 'if I've is now well
supported the rook is beautiful on h3
defending c3 and pressure against h7 you
don't want a queen exchange as why
White's going for the attack f5 Queen
here soon enough
right now can you afford to give up that
pawn not quite black queen of bother
white soon enough though here here or
here first maybe now this is me King
here check and then check me game over
the dock wins again
okay the doc is in first with 46 a
10-point lead let's let's let's stick
with the doc let's stick with the doc
now the last time these two played ARCA
was way up on time but ended up getting
mated another about a 10-second lead all
right one minor piece off can black pull
off one more minor piece exchange that
would be desirable once more white
working with some space
I'm Roxy bind
b5 is under control okay we have the
other pawn break in the position I guess
here with a5 and check that a for this
pawns are in that Knights just falling
Lacs up a piece this is not enough
compensation it could be shut down with
e5 and just offering exchanges look at
that move look at how quickly this is
recognized Knight to e6 you have recover
in May we got that
and just mopping up some more pieces may
threat
they're first though me in a couple oh
this is brutal this is brutal watch okay
maybe we take a time can we do that can
we take a time out from watching the doc
where's uh where's penguin penguin is
still suffering on his tablet
let's see penguin playing probably still
on his tablet or not now he might he
might have put the tablet down he might
be playing for real now all right
maybe he's at his his home corner he's
up with Pease up a queen penguin is up a
queen here things are things are looking
bright for the penguin currently number
thirty ninth that's not gonna last for
long he's had enough of these losses
should have won that first ring against
Caruana maybe had a mouse slip or
something or a finger slip all right
let's just see how he converts this and
we'll see one right from the top of the
key
let's break it down here with e6 so many
ways to do it
night check there goes the rook just
like that and you're up ten seconds by
the way penguin you can't beat this you
can't be penguin on time don't try it
don't try to beat the penguin on time it
just doesn't happen alright check and
then I'm ain't next whether the King
goes here here alright this guy could
have resigned a long while ago
whoa anyone realized that there was a
queen here Wow my blind what happened is
that there was a queen so close to the
king okay anyhow let's see one more by
the penguin or two more and we'll call
two more with the penguin he's coming up
the ranks here he jumped up a handful of
spots there he's in xxx how'd he do it
okay black is down upon but has a killer
bishop the most important defender for
the white king is gonzo so blacks
looking to attack that's the
compensation white as a pawn but white
has a vulnerable King
and an annoying night is nearby pieces
are converging towards the king
intersecting the queen is said she needs
to find a new square where is it safe
square for the Queen she's drifted away
from the Kings side Queen can't go too
far has a responsibility on f3 Queen is
hit again okay a3 she was on h3 now
she's on a three there we go tricky
Knight hits two minor pieces for the
rook this is excellent for team black do
not fall for mate this time penguin
don't do it this is secure a king is on
the same color square as the bishop and
currently we have rook to e2 or check
and then rook to e2 the queen is going
to be gun there's no issue fourteen
black
penguin is cleaning house in this one he
will not lose this one
never
it's not happening not even okay there
we go
not mate just yet this square is covered
just wants to get rid of one of the
rooks or both rooks yeah and at this
point penguin only needs point zero one
seconds and he's gonna win watch one
more and take a peek at the and there we
go watch one more by the penguin are
still waiting for the penguin to get in
his next game
doctor is still in first penguin has
just been paired up again against
fighter man 91 Penguins ins 28th versus
the number 18 spot GM battle
one hour and 27 minutes to go in this
event
1/k first prize
all right
I've got a check there's no takes here
and there was a pin both sides gonna be
uncounseled and I could have inserted a
check there on drops just getting out of
any checks opposite sides castling so
material and not nearly as important as
an attack against the enemy king so
blacks up a pawn but white has some
files to work with 38 seconds
team black keeping the Queen's on no
Queen exchange a5 push both rooks can be
playing soon flight square would be h3
at this stage and there's pressure on c7
it's easily defended though how do you
get rid of this bishop
something like this a sacrifice and then
crashing through on c7 is an idea
counterpunch against the Queen Queen
takes for a queen takes rook has a check
on this square depending on where the
Queen goes and you could go straight in
here now right here can't block with the
Queen
the knight is not falling just yet
Knight on b5 or c6 as well as Queen
takes Knight here this is the deadly
threat under 10 seconds there's no look
at the time situation don't even look at
the position lay the clock 26 seconds to
2
due to too fast the penguin was too fast
in that 162 of the dock is in first
let's go back over the dock
let's watch the dock he's paired up
against Caruana
how are things looking here not good for
the doc he's down a piece up sometime
but I prefer team white here being up
the piece yeah conversion shouldn't be
too difficult I don't like the rook
position and I must say takes him a
little bit to kind of get active okay
now he's getting the piece back
clock is evening out rook and pawn any
amalrik and rook any herbs are drawn
right then we're gonna see about that
Hawk you stopping this oh he went right
in three pawns versus the rook four
seconds each under five the doc the doc
is winning this this is a blast oh man
this is a blast alright let's stick
around let's see what this uh what the
doc has up his sleeve again okay
and first
he is in first no I didn't want to go
there let's just stay on the dock I'm
jumping around too much let's stay on
the dock
okay slim mg is pointing out I'm right
hammer pointed on this stream this is
Magnus okay
so I haven't been able to stay off the
chat here apparently this is Carlson
apparently dr. drunken Stein is Carlson
all right he may be the doc is nuts he's
he's in timeout or something I don't
want to go there oh I see what I'm
clicking on Oh
I mean to click there and let's find
somebody okay he's back in a game
it wasn't it wasn't loading there
all right team black might as well call
Carlson then at this stage
all right
brutal men how to commentate to Carlsen
Bulacan how do you do it
Forks gang move and then your
crashing through on each for killer man
look at the clock situation too
okay white resigned just just laugh at
the the speed and then say white
resigned Carlson's opponent resigned
again alright ARCA again so this is the
number one Carlson against the number
two seed not an excuse me not the number
to see the current number two in the in
the tourney one versus two Lou brutal
check sacking the Queen okay can Carlson
fight back two minor pieces versus the
Queen we're gonna see can't take this
bishop just yet now it's a threat hang
on to the bishop could trade one let's
see how dangerous the night is White has
some pressure here for sure where's the
safe spot for the king any a five maybe
be five look at the light squares the
minor pieces have security
how can the queen break down the white
structure blacks gonna give back some
material and then it's material
advantage isn't to really you know there
we go got the exchange this is a nice
shelter even on the clock
both rooks are centralized there was a
queen a4 threat he's running over here
now one pawn is falling gotta be careful
of this idea can you try it now uh he
was looking for this he's being sneaky
he's getting made it he got mated oh
okay
all right duck you you are a beast and a
half
oh man okay he's he is at probably one
more win away and he's cracking 2,900 he
had a twenty nine hundred plus
performance rating in the first one
which isn't insane Wow
yeah I I think we're gonna maybe stick
around on the UH and drunken stun for a
bit we still have a lot of time to go
though an hour and 20 I wanna take a
peek at the standings alright well I
don't see how he folds this one off he's
III I checked the chat for a moment and
then it's down a piece although now he's
winning the Queen I guess we won the
piece back but I have to feel that this
FM could still win here it's definitely
the better position didn't didn't he
have it here no okay the rook could have
blocked
look there's good you should be able to
convert this up so many pawns team light
rock check clean here
to be a little bit careful here the
pressure on f2 yeah
Karlsson resigned in that one - Harry -
here Joseph one that went okay Munir
these pairings are so fast
I don't - two and a half one and a half
is the score between these two
okay get them get in the d5 pressure on
h2 just going to launch the H fun here
we go
dar Square bishops off first huh
hmm Bishop takes rook and no Mike has a
file to work with Wow he just he doesn't
care about the pawns here just queenside
castle
you got the bishop you got the night you
got the rook got the Queen you got a
check here trying to pick up the rook
and you have made on each one don't
forget who cares about the rock yeah
let's take the rook get that rookies are
protected No we care more about giving
checkmate rook h1 oh man all right
off-white is the opponent who could stop
this beast who's gonna do it oh this
just seems too simple
makes it look too simple it's not it's
not it's not this simple oh boy
big problems
perfect structure on the kingside
back up get the night in here one of
these two this is multi-purpose break
down the structure and got a flight
square and the night is making his
rounds to two beautiful squares first
doubling up no trades just yet passed
pawn
one priority White has to try and hunt
this down fast and no not so fast you
could trade it off no two rooks for the
Queen
okay now the King has to get over here
interesting King should be on this
square
oneexchange well this pond is going to
be one
King here and then this no you're not
gonna go into a king and pawn in game
keeping the rook on board look at the
time off White has a 13 second advantage
FM Black has a passed pawn is it a one
King and pawn in game yeah it is these
pawns are all frozen these three pawns
restrict these four
so it's an extra pawn here and he's
going to push through you know just a
quicker assessment of that King and pawn
endgame their Queen here grab the pawn
push another one
yeah I just resigned 10 seconds is
plenty
Lenny okay where we at 78 users running
away with it
brutal okay let's check out Kara wanna
for a few games
how about Kara wanna we're on his
channel right now and let's see Caruana
it looks like a drop and this one will
watch one right from the top
you know I don't know both pliers are
just going to put their pawns on light
squares there's no targets for either
Bishop
okay there's no there's no real headway
to make over here King just stays put
King is going to try to get behind like
this you know just a little repetition
let's see one right from the top
seventy-eight for its of race for second
place 78 47 47 okay Caruana right from
the beginning against toy rock number
three versus number eight
okay what to note with this one
note something fast before it's the
endgame
if Y could win this pawn is just clearly
better it's currently down upon this
Bishop is not so productive it's a
really nice square on d5 both the 9th of
Bishop kick him away you have these
squares under control
you know White is in the drivers and
drivers seat with these light squares
okay
black census this needs to open up the
diagonal for the dark square Bishop
counter punches at both the knight pawns
what is up upon and Queen exchange or
not okay
even in this endgame there's some
pressure that I can eventually exert on
f7 even though the Queen's aren't around
these become critical points f7 and f2
this Bishop can get it f7 whereas this
Bishop can't get f2 that factors in
so there's an F for idea looking for
some mate here okay we have a passed
pawn bishop post here and we're gonna
have it we're gonna have okay there's an
attempt to stop Bishop here the the rook
doesn't want to see the bishop here and
now the bishop won't be denied the b3
square it's a perfect spot so now the
rooks need to come off anticipating this
pressure against f7 the King needs to
run over here and escort the pawn is he
gonna be fast enough maybe there's still
a a passed pawn that can be created over
here he's putting a halt to that don't
want to put too many white pawns on
light squares these guys could be hunted
down what's the clock situation eleven
seconds for white eight seconds under
eight fourteen black can't go too far
here this should be a draw and this guy
could pull off a lot of moves fast
believe me that's ultra bullet
20800 ultra bullet that's 15 second
chests but the position is not looking
too good
three seconds to one second no time on
the clock point zero seven point triple
zeros call it down on time okay
well we could always go to Carlsen
let's we're gonna see plenty of Carlson
games let's see let's see somebody named
how about Nirvana 95 I saw I said at the
beginning I want to check out a game or
two by this nirvana 95 and here we go a
newer a newer GM let's see what Nirvana
95 can can show us here still plenty of
time 1 hour 12 minutes to go you could
see that right here you know before the
tournament started I was looking at how
many games the players how many games
were played by each of the players and
it's somewhere around 65 games you get
in in the two hours so still a lot more
chests to be played
and good strategy probably to eliminate
this guy eliminate dark square bishop
Sankar anchor and night on the f4 square
black is now up the exchange probably
play some pawns on light squares at this
point make sure he stays under control
and there we go the dark square bishop
SAR going to be gun and black just wants
to crack open some more lines
I like this keeping the rook here so
that there's an a5 move prying open the
the Queen side some get here isn't this
gonna be a little bit annoying Bishop
his office at the king house the clock
situation 34 seconds 10 seconds for
nirvana 95 connected passer how to break
down the structure feels like you should
try to maybe give up some material
[Music]
we're gonna see okay something
falling here take and then push now
there's an in-betweener
first to check too much material sneak
the King over to f6 now push the pawn
just to give a check improve the King
position you know ten seconds that
second advantage is still there
black shouldn't have any issue
converting this just give some material
back chop chop win all the white pawns
plenty of ways to do it evening out a
little bit on the clock okay now he's
going to just just be up a full rook can
you pull this one off less than two
seconds for team white oh well the rook
has gone push push push a little
stepladder okay that game is over
oh it's let's let's stay right here
let's watch one more by Nirvana 95 then
current number 15 in the tournament
versus number 37 Gannicus
okay yeah might as well pick up this
pawn no no no no we got it we got a fork
there on c7 and that's so fast so the
Queen's are off the black king is on
castled still looking for these ideas
okay we've even f5 yeah f5 without the
Queen's on board that nearly is
uncomfortable for the black king
ton of weaknesses are created with that
five but can they be exploited
interesting shot takes takes and then
there's a little pin on the D file but
what do we have here
hunt down this pawn fast he's a great
thorn in the side there's a good square
on g4 for the bishop hmm
King here the rook enters rook here
there's some knight move now this Knight
is enormous and there's a fork right
around the corner I feel it's close to
happening
down I'm liking team light here for sure
well definitely no I blinked once more
and a piece just as gonner yeah this
conversion shouldn't be too hard
Gannicus is super super fast
giving the piece back now that was not
that was not the plan this pawn can take
off one step away the King needs to now
help it's cut off for the moment are
these guys gonna play it out a little
rat race in this one yeah at this point
you don't want to even spend any time
offering hit rock because you're just
gonna if your opponent doesn't accept
then you're just wasting time that one
ends up as a drop let's see how things
are looking 98 doctor drunken Stein
let's jump over to the penguin
let's let's see a couple of games on
penguin is paired up against Caruana
so are they having a repeat of their
first game of the tournament
not quite
alright let's see let's see the
conversion here dropping a six but both
eight ponds are gone
I like team white here isolated pond I
don't see the the dynamism
with having the isolated pawn in this
position a little bit too simplified now
the bishop needs to find a new square
and another pawn is dropping two pawns
down penguin is two pawns down currently
in fifth
need to keep some material on but light
has perfect coordination and is looking
to remove a beautiful piece on e6 one of
the better pieces on in blacks position
the bishop on e6 so makes sense to
challenge that piece breaking down the
structure h5 flight square on each -
okay what's the clock
24:14 black
can the penguin fight back being down
only now a pawn bishop is hit
chips
okay let's see if the penguin can pull
this one off all the repetition no
definitely want some more these guys are
just incredibly fast h2 the Queen Queen
check here just get the just to get the
Queen's off on f2 gonna target f2 just
wants the Queen's off at this point
penguins gonna win this you're not
beating the penguin you're not beating
the penguin and these endings I just
know it I just know it he okay yeah it's
it's it's over I have too much
experience playing against the penguin
point zero one is all he needs
I'm telling you point zero one let's
track the penguin again he's coming up
the ranks here okay oh here we go
penguin mr. Andrew let's call it Carlsen
versus ting
all righty this is where you want to be
the number one versus the number 4g4
take the pawn I want to kill your king
Wow
this is hitting so fast the center is
strong you can plan the the wings here
is there gonna be a sacrifice on g6
don't be surprised in there we go clean
is turning into pac-man looking for
mates Queen Czech pawn push at some
point white is down a piece but this is
not a comfortable King oh boy uncle
penguin is gonna be crying uncle soon I
think that's a backbreaker isn't it
Queens are gonna be exchanged King takes
Knight Queen here is that a mate that's
a mate oh that's brutal man that's
brutal
alright let's let's see let's see
another one still by the penguin we'll
be seeing more of the the doc
Karlsson
wow what a what a what a move on g4 just
cave Manish
okay these guys have played a couple
times current man scored 315 to 188 just
in just a few games it's gonna be down a
piece counterpunch against the bishop
we're almost at the halfway point in
this tournament doctor drunken Stein is
definitely running away with this one
maybe the the first titled arena was
just some kind of a warm-up just kind of
learning learning how to move the mouse
or something because that is such a
significant lead it's like 30 40 point
lead over the number two Wow
okay better position for white
why is the night not being captured here
what was the delay with that move not
sure what else was being considered
there yeah if you take right away he's
gonna be one right back so he rather
just keep some pressure hmm once again
going to have this why does the better
side considering these squares here King
Bishop two squares rook has to make sure
he sticks around defending this point
the King needs to help out under 10
seconds penguin okay let's see these
guys are both just so fast we're gonna
sneak in a little g3 some little bullet
idea or a quick be six and the speed is
just so much at any point black is
probably pre moving this and that's why
white isn't playing it straight away and
it just got made
okay let's try another one let's follow
let's see a couple of games with Caruana
let's see currently number eight Caruana
versus the number two ARCA fifty
ARCA 50 didn't finish in the money than
the first one so how is this one looking
here that's looking good for team black
there are a bunch of ponds can you stop
all these ponds hmm no these ponds are
too much can't stop them both Caruana
resigned okay this is currently where we
are at 106 75-65 5757 these top five are
currently all on the money 1000 250 125
75 and 50 let's jump into another one
and who can argue with checking out this
one again there we go just click on that
board right here so we're just under the
one hour mark
let's see is there a perpetual
can you get away with taking
and then look for checks here oh what's
the idea with this move just look here
and then Queen takes pawn all right
let's see what a white comes up with you
a little pawn push there is a perpetual
at minimum well I just had one more move
and he is going to go for that
and this shouldn't be enough wow he
really is he really is trying for mate
we're gonna have a mate oh my God we're
getting mate here on g2 just let's just
stay on this channel oh wow
it didn't look like Carlson's King was
gonna get mated and then you just just
don't blink twice if you blink twice
you're gonna miss it
Wow
oh man okay so he's playing the Benoni
fun this is a lot of fun pressure on the
B file okay can you get a piece to d6
the bishop I guess is going to be the
block hater now this now that the Vaughn
is gone or the night has gone from f6
these guys can start to play
down upon but a very good structure he
could be won back and yeah first cutting
off the rook probably wanna King under
that bishop ha now the knight is well
under control scoop out the bishop now
I'm just getting the rook out of harm's
way so there's no discovered attack
against the rook and then we'll attack
against the Queen and the rook oh my god
just smashing right through there goes
the Queen f4f to Bishop Queen and Brooke
all attacking the king now check a check
a bishop here and then a maid on g2 just
resigned he knows it's coming the light
squares are just too much might there
have been some defense with the knight -
III but no there's nothing nothing to do
okay
57 mark
ever'one yeah I don't think that's going
to change this is a race to see who he
gets second place
so fast Wow
all righty light-square control is the
name of the game
Knight is under control with the C pawn
the c3 pawn and now we're playing on the
F file huh it's okay with giving this
pawn up wants to attack the king is the
queen trapped no the night's gonna be
anchored in here you're gonna pick up
another pawn no not taking up another
pond there's Knight g3 with the fork
that has a thorn that is 1b sleep on
Queen g3 defends Queen takes h2 no Queen
exchange here runs into me
only now and the night is hit
we got checks we got a night move we
want to get in here and he is gonna
sneak in there it's night is hitting
everything look at the clock
thirty-eight seconds so TAC isn't going
anywhere
oh that was interesting maybe it is and
maybe it is going somewhere but it
doubled up on the clock now that's the
big cost I found a way to get the Queens
off but look at how much time it took
just game came over no that's beautiful
that's beautiful
the old deflection up the exchange and
nearly 20 seconds in a 1 minute game is
a lot ok Dimitri the number 5 guy I
don't believe this account was playing
in the first run Oh Karel Khan huh
not taking with the Jeep on just the
epon ok two bishops no doesn't want the
night
doesn't want to damage the pawn
structure that was a mouse lip
you know it's just launching the G&H
ponds he's got the pieces pointed here
both bishops a rook don't forget about
the night he could enter to at some
point he could jump in some kind of
discovering all these pieces are
pointing at the King almost mate Knights
gonna be sweeping in let's just see how
this game how black wins this one and I
don't see how you stop this attack the
knight is actually pretty good defender
okay one rook is off making a little bit
more technical just picking up upon
passer he's immediately running but now
there's a wonderful square this is too
much exchanges guard dark square bishop
gotta be something good here rook is hit
counter punch against the black rook
even on the clock
take care still have a pass
okay still up a pond can you take care
and still be winning no I'm gonna try
something else maybe Oh could do this is
that a draw she might be a draw if they
traded the bishop's I think the King and
pawn in game is a draw
Oh big slip they're being really sneaky
here bishop there who does that a sneaky
player ha ha ha
very sneaky Dimitri put the bishop
yeah that's one of those bullet tricks
53 minutes to go in this tournament
okay Carlson versus oper
let's see
another Queens gambit declined I feel
that they played this the the first time
yeah they're repeating the same line
okay it's a little bit different there's
a quick capture on e5 instead of
allowing white to first play F 4 and
then recapture at the F pawn these two
pawns and the minor pieces the rooks the
Queen are going to look to do some
damage
white doesn't even want the rook once
once the one that's free valuing more
the knight now this is just broken down
up the exchange you want to open some
files more lines the better
oh boy
here Queen here how do you stop it in 18
I can win call it in a very fast pairing
Carlson one and one fast in that one in
exchange karo the white end oh man
okay the F file is gonna play a role I
imagine how do you get rid of this night
my own Osaka rook forum Queen exchange
at the cost of pawn structure okay let's
see this conversion night here is pretty
strong no no that's that's a secure
square there would it be a rook exchange
first he's not going anywhere I like
blacks position even on the clock
probably just Park him right here
d5 that's the safe square Knights are
definitely being annoying here but I
mean this is a better position for black
for sure take that pawn yeah
and the clock is not an issue for black
up upon clear pond uh he's giving up
that pond four versus three there's a
passer tough to convert this though
pawns all on one side of the board could
always be annoying to wait offering a
rook exchange still up on the clock
black up upon and on the clock up on the
clock
neither King is safe
can constantly be checked with the rooks
this should be a draw but the clock
that's gonna factor in it's evening out
on the clock pitching one pawn still a
draw who has the faster Mouse rookie
there is still draw it's still another
draw okay this should be a drop yeah be
able to it should be repetition any
second now and there we go next move
stalemate or just two kings okay
49 minutes left one hundred and nineteen
eighty one seventy six seventy sixty
eight I'm gonna take a quick skip
through all the pages you could see
where your favorite players are
currently positioned page three still
gonna get to see plenty more games yeah
just a quick cycle through see everybody
else that's in there yeah page nine page
ten go faster go faster
yeah some players I've entered and then
with it's drawn I understand it's a
brutal field alright who do we want how
about this guy here let's let's check
out the warning what's the what's the
warning up to let's watch a game by the
warning
this one gonna get fired up here yeah
they are they aren't playing let's go
back over to Carlson Oh Carlson Caruana
right Carlson with black but white just
resigned being up a rook Knights under
control there's no issue here against
the black king okay Oh number one and
number two from Norway doing battle
Carlson versus John Ludwig hammer
all right
I imagine they've they've played this
position before sure they've played
plenty of bullet games together
the pond black doesn't want it or
doesn't know he's still not taking on c3
Oh where's the king gonna get safe f2
Queen sneaks in allows a check and then
the bishop falls brutal pin this rook is
not playing rook here you take the rook
and then you just pile up on the pinned
piece this is game over you're gonna
have resignation here no good solution
brutal rook takes
or that
plenty of ways to do it I guess he's
going straight for meat huh he wants to
win the rook with check okay it's not
happening I don't see any perpetual
against the white king though and there
we go that's a mate all right doctor
let's uh see who
all right let's go into the penguin game
number three this really feels like
we're it's gonna be the fight fight for
second place
but who knows could have a last last
second run
penguin is third ARCA is second
yeah I am tongue-tied
alrights these bishops are very scary
support the knight or runaway I'm going
to have a fork here but there's an
attack on the bishop so the bishop
preserved and this is defended these are
just so scary bishop a queen coming out
in this direction at some stage this
square is defended black wants to get in
there can't go too far the rook has to
defend the knight and now a shattered
King side structure we're gonna have
some type of a rook lift Queen
light-square weakness is just some kind
of deflection you know Queen take struck
why knows it's coming
Queen takes rook there's Bishop takes g3
Queen is sneaking in and that's going to
be ball game penguin goes down arca is a
beast
okay let's watch another one by the
penguin
line up 123 85 80 7675 is where we stand
okay penguin versus John Ludwig hammer
let's see yeah I'm the few games I've
played against hammer he he does this a
knight to e7 post quite a bit
ninety-seven of fianchetto a c5 d5 in
some order no exchanges why not
White has the safer King maybe the Queen
could stir up some trouble at some stage
pieces are drifting over there Queen
takes pawn serious threat there's a
knight move all that's slick on takes
Queen takes Bishop and mate soon enough
I'll check first and then here and this
night yeah thank you get the Queen here
where's the threat though any Queen move
and then there's a knight f6 two
different checks available there is a
passed pawn the bishop is a pretty
strong piece the rooks watch over these
squares from the Queen checks Queen is
getting trapped oh that's unfortunate
Queen isn't trap the Queen is trapped
here no save square d8 is covered who
let's let's see what he's gonna pull off
here oh he found he found something no
he didn't he's down a rock
he's down hook I was very unfortunate
he's just gonna simplify he's up on the
black is up on the clock as well I don't
see how this one gets pulled off save
that pond yeah I'll be able to convert
sacrifice the bishop for the pond
down on the clock as well mmm very
unfortunate rook there and the Queen
just was out of squares
she was so active combined really well
with the knight devotes what can you do
that's bullet all right Oh gorilla
ten to seven is their match score all
right penguin plays this structure a lot
we're gonna have no no trade on e4
doesn't want to invite that night
forward doesn't want to exchange the
night either so night on the rim
fighting for the f5 square I don't like
I really don't like blacks position I
think that this is gonna hurt
f5 the bishop really isn't playing here
son is he's on his heels black is on his
heels this Knight is in some trouble
yeah
careful now Bishop goes too far he
doesn't have a square some move like
this okay he has a square now but now
that's going to be taken away sooner I
thought it could be it with G for this
Knight is a killer night here with this
idea
a major piece on board this King is
never comfortable never and white has
control over the only open file I really
like that night I wasn't surprised to
see that white gave up that strong night
for the bishop nice there's a main
threat and the Queen was on the rook
penguins fighting back down on the clock
but very active Queen though prefer
black year for sure things turned really
fast
rook takes rook runs into mate first we
have a check can we pull off some check
yeah check here and then take the rook
whit's check and here we go
that one's gonna do it where's the mink
there it is no resignation the King had
a move but it's made soon enough rook
age to next all right let's see another
one try I'll check the penguin again
currently in third
versus Cara Juana
I don't know how many games they've
they've played they've played three or
two no this is their third game now in
this tournament
and in all games the penguin was black
penguin playing black in all games
against Caruana tough majority on the
queenside
Knight on f4 launched some pawns here
these guys can still create a passer
jumping right in don't have to take here
right away then where the bond was on
the Queen this is a really good piece
has to find a new home I like blacks
position the bishop is non-existent the
Knight has a wonderful square and the
Queen wants into h1 King is going to
have to flee
what's that move about just
the bishop I guess huh yeah this rook is
out of play the bishop really isn't
doing anything I like blacks pieces
holding off on that capture okay now we
have Queen h4 this King is gonna suffer
incoming discovery now this is getting
broken down fast this was this was a
sharp play man that was sharp all the
blacks pieces just fell on really really
good squares rook on the seventh but
he's actually one of the worst pieces
Believe It or Not under control by the
bishop that was a really nice win very
very nice when how about we're at this
point in the tournament with less than
40 minutes to go we're sticking around
here the number one versus the number
four operas having a very good
tournament and let's see
I don't seen 35 seconds to 22
I feel that opera should be able to no I
don't know about this now now this is
this is very difficult to hold in blitz
and it try some kind of work around the
bishop doesn't want the King to cross
yeah it's gonna is he gonna try to just
burn a time now you cannot dislodge this
you know give a check to the king
yeah he's you know he's just gonna work
the clock yeah and the night sure enough
Lanza Fork
okay jumping around a little bit too
much there let's let's let's stay right
here so the current standings 143 it
really is a runaway for first place
143 87 next to me 143 89 80 78380
okay another one
number one Carlsen versus little peasant
this is Alejandro Ramirez
team black
efore is in a fork is threatened and
white is down upon but has the bishop
pair and a little bit of space and this
Knight is ready to circle into d6 oh my
goodness so fast man
okay the bishops are still around this
is this is so wicked fast a knight on d6
is just kind of ball game how do you how
do you cope with these discover checks
you're gonna win so much in yer you're
just down the exchange a knight on d6
cannot put a value of just three points
on that guy he's too much too valuable
he can't get out this pin rook move and
then you're gonna be up a bishop soon
rook takes out both the knight and
Bishop a resigned time
twenty-nine by the way have you noticed
the rating of Carlson 29:45 okay let's
watch another one number one versus
number four
a race for second a race for the 250
dollar prize the fantasy variation of
the Carol con f3 he does this against me
I shall watch it very closely
what does Carlson do against the fantasy
variations Queen b6 in Fe and cut out
okay noted and he's willing to give away
upon huh okay he's getting it back here
some Tempe to be gained against the
Queen
picking up c2 or maybe even sweeping
into b2
now we take now only take on b2 Knight
takes pawn with check what's the King
gonna do he can't castle in either
direction and we have a check soon first
development how does the King get safe
we're safe ground for the white king
black rooks are entering and Knight
moves and then crashing through on c2
happens
the clotted you do you realize how I
don't know how many of you in the chat
have played against upper this guy is so
fast but look at his clock it's at ten
seconds to 30 seconds it's just amazing
horsey here this is so fast
ah
it's really this is really incredible
stuff this is way way way too difficult
to keep up with
wicked fast
well he's he's fought back some for sure
on the clock
but it was it was 30 seconds to 10
seconds at one point that isn't I don't
know speechless I know I'm just
commenting this game on the the clock
but it's just so impressive it really is
151 89 89 85 well let's jump over to
[Music]
let's see let's see over here alright
we're gonna watch another one battle of
the Norway guys let's let's watch
Carlson playing
team black here different perspective
Jean Ludvig hammer against Carlson
25:29 59 rating
incredible
you know just just just just watch just
watch okay I don't know how to assess
this this pond is very deep there's some
light square weaknesses the king is
never comfortable with the Queen's on
the board and a pawn on h3 like this
this bishop is excellent we have some
checks thrown in is this rook in some
trouble I could just retreat he's really
on the defense up about 10 seconds is
Carlsen rook takes pawn or pawn takes
pawn can be played here as pawn is
pinned
it's just deciding which one to go with
you could take with the pawn this square
is covered I'm missing here why is he
going into such a think-tank here well I
must have been missing something for
sure huh yeah I was clearly
missing something there must have been
as easy as being able to capture on e4
Queen is pinned though by the way queen
is gone did you blink again if you blink
you miss something okay six seconds each
Queen is mopping things up you could
take out the rook to Queens on the scene
game over soon enough where's the mate
there it is
brutal brutal
okay 93 who cares about first 155 let's
see okay I care about first we're gonna
we're not Carlsen again we're at the
30-minute thirty minutes left
ra carlson playing white against dimitri
how did this one go last time yeah they
they split games third a third time
playing against each other now
already Queen just I just wanted to try
I wanted a second I wanted a second or
two to assess this position in black
resigned okay
these Carlson's opponents are resigning
faster than I could assess the position
they need to they need to at least give
me a few seconds hope that that guy
assess the position really then I'll
resign holy cow
thirty nine seventy it only took eleven
seconds look at how easy that's all
eleven seconds all right let's look at
these guys this really is a race for
second place 159 97 not even close
penguin versus ARCA ooh look how look at
this seventy each match score Wow
I don't know who are casaya thinks in
there their profile
very nice score
you're not gonna see that so much
against penguin a match score 50%
that's excellent
okay what to do about efore is a for
gonna fall
white has some pressure against the king
f5 a night a Rupp take some time out to
take that phone yeah he's going straight
for me
how did defend g7 and let's see how you
defend that it's pawns crashing through
take again
take again and then you're on e6
what's penguin considering here Knight
takes Knight takes pawn what's the issue
with pawn takes pawn here Wow he gave up
on the the attack they're down a rook
now no probably miss something there
hmmm he's down on he's down on the clock
as well
hmm I must have missed something I trust
penguin more than I do myself there it
could have been any I don't know how to
describe that one well what was I
missing somebody in the chat
anyhow
on to the next game less than a half
hour to go 27 minutes and change
penguin against opera number two versus
number four penguin is in second
already
yeah these bishops are strong the Queen
will contribute as well all all pointing
at the White King Knights are connected
this is a fine structure for the King
whites Bishop's are potent both bishops
are pointing at each other's kings
a reposition for the night I'm ready to
target b-41 ruck exchange no we gotta
pond
drop back to defend or just pick up a
piece you know the Knights are
offsetting Black is still up upon Queen
here there's rook here you know this
Knight is gonna have a perfect square up
five seconds how do you want to do it
keep the Queen on Queen takes Knight
Queen takes rook main threat on g2
you know there's some tactic right
around the corner where's the tactic
looking for a rook here black has the
safe square on h7 flight square Queen
takes pawn g3 yeah there's the rookie
six move
even on the clock 16 each
stockfish says to take says quick burger
in the channel noted okay we have a fork
here eight seconds
oh and he's on the Queen at the end
opera is gonna win this one is up on the
clock end up were up
this is too much to come back from
ya have to watch out for steal me
yeah he's got him penguin went down okay
let's see how things are looking
we'll be referring to this page towards
the end here these last 25 minutes 159
nine okay forget about it Carlson is
gonna win who's in second 97 93 92 87
alright let's jump in new game
Karlsson again
team black Carlson fourth game between
these two
safer King 14 black tricky Knight versus
the rook these guys are too much yeah
this night is just way too good there's
gonna be there's gonna be a tactic
pulled off very soon very soon hmm
can the knight find a better square
there it is now you can't do this
straight away because Queen takes and
there's a pin just do it like that
switch the order see how simple and he
already calculated he'll be able to stop
the pawn the kinky get inside this can
get inside the box
easy peasy for the world champion
how many of you can have pulled that one
off that fast
raise your hand
how about we go over to where's okay car
one is in tenth
let's jump
into another game
we're gonna see who's gonna get paired
up with Carlson I guess so fast space
now
no e5 in this position he captured
there's gonna be an issue on the dark
squares hmm haven't played this player
alright no I guess I have played a
couple times major piece specific clean
ending alone three versus two on the
Queen side is where the attention will
be here we go past fun trade chop and
then here he's calculating can he get
over here in time and I guess it's not
working out I'll try I'll trust
I'll just Carlsen on health okay
now black insist you should capture here
and now this is easy
yeah he'll be able to get here in time
King here he gets flushed back and now
an outside passer wins push here
pac-man soon enough let's see you play
out
oh he just wants to win the pawn
outright you don't have to push him he
could just win him next
zooks long that's what they say I think
I think that's what they say all right
penguin how are you doing you're in you
have 99 you don't have fire opera has
fire let's let's check out opera a big
game
oh and opera just one let's watch one
more let's watch one more by opera opera
is in he has ninety eight one point
behind penguin and he has fire a wind
for opera here and he goes up four more
points in the standings this is a really
important win really important game
Scotch opening or scotch variation
this is a
the game that I currently have on the
last game I cover it on YouTube this
opening audubon with white against
Carlsen at this exact position but close
Bishop pair for white
can't take care bishop h-2b 3fe and keto
isolated pawn bishop there watches over
rook c3 this still may hit at some point
this bishop is a wonderful supporter of
a passed pawn
okay some space and looking to clamp
down on this structure some Mike just
continues to push 32 seconds for opera
20 minutes to go in the tournament
you know he's right and this is not the
ideal placement for the rook and this
pawn could be defended with the Queen
and then the brook can be pushed away
and the bishop can't go here to prevent
this idea and nor can you do this the
bishop can take the pond so the bishop
sneaks in yep
removing the block hater is f2 an issue
it isn't yeah in black resigns and with
that opera jumps up to second 102 101
it's very very close let's let's stay in
with stayin hopper okay he's paired up
against a tough one a little tough
opponent a little tough opponent Carlson
vs. hopper is what we have is this where
his streak is going to end you know he
entered this tournament with about a
twenty three hundred rating so he has
shot up a good 500 points so he was
missing in the first titled arena
currently he is blanked by Carlson the
match score is 6-0 Carlson's going for
win number seven these pawns are gonna
run office of color bishops the white
pawns do a very good job of restricting
these pawns notice the difference with
the pawn structure this is the kind of
harmony would want pawns on dark Bishop
on light black doesn't have that over
here so it's tough to get this majority
rolling these guys clamped down
meanwhile the attention is going to be
over here on the kingside some type of
timely h5 break mm-hmm
now this rook could be cut off and it
seems like he's just going to be scooped
up
this king can run all the way over here
a for just don't even allow this pawn to
push everything is locked no forward
progress and look at the clock
oh man 37 seconds to 12 brutal
all right let's see another one 165 105
102 so the penguin is now in second
let's let's have a look at the Penguins
game he's on fire
a win here very important and it appears
that he's gonna pull this enough it's up
a boatload of material and that's a win
okay 110 102
let's stay would stay on the penguin
here he's now paired against ARCA French
no exchange French and advanced French
white wants the light square bishop
exchange let's see how he deals with
this structure Queen is currently
cutting the King off no castling just
yet
dark-squared bishop exchange queenside
castle got to make a decision black
where's where's it gonna be some fancy
tactic on f7 night h7
Wow no no can't counsel night h7 you
don't see that too often Wow the white
pieces are very active the King is
caught in the middle and now we have the
night blocked the rook queenside castle
is available for just a second but black
is now down a piece how good is this
Neethu
can he be rescued probably right take a
timeout for a queen takes pawn but no be
very careful the Queen's going to be
able to enter got to keep the rook on
need two pieces for the attack black
also needs a flight square sneaky can't
take the Queen you get back rank mated
13 seconds he's finding away in this
night this night is stuck over here
black has a passed pawn who's ready to
push you the rook can take the fun you
know a rook takes pawn there's a queen
check and then Queen takes gotta be
careful the back rank yeah there we go
he's winning the rook this knight he
remains there and now he scooped up
penguin has this one Wow
he fought back he was down a knight but
how good was that night on h7 not good
enough 167 114 of a gap ten point gap
between second and third how about we
check out no no let's see if opera could
maybe sneak in a game here
there I should be clicking over here
watch a couple of games with hopper go
to his channel
Oh quick resigner there okay so how are
the are the standings looking now he has
fire 114 to 106 let's see if opera could
get in another game
okay number 24 number three versus the
number 24 guy
very typical idea especially in bullet
chests launched in the h-bomb like this
yeah whenever you have that fianchetto
though you want to do this first or take
the Queen you go here and then take
what's the body count
minor piece for the Queen currently none
of the above all so here you're just
going to go like that
Queen could be taken so is white gonna
save the material it servants it's just
beyond me to really calculate this fast
enough okay I understand
lights up the exchange
and he's going to be able to simplify a
little bit more wants to save the bishop
okay this is scary I was a fan of maybe
doing this but that's why I am I'm 300
points behind opera
[Laughter]
oh okay
some simplification it's not it's not
squeaky clean here for the the White
King like has been putting a lot of
pressure on white and that's why we see
white down on time under ten seconds now
but I'm not I don't know how yeah he has
a three to one lead here and now that
pond is gonna Queen you could go over
here he could he could have run over
here hmm cuz this pond is gonna Queen
okay he doesn't have fire anymore
118 108 let's watch another one he's in
third still looking to get into the
second place here
another instance here this attacking
that g3b three moves with the roof on at
any moment you're constantly guessing
when is blacken and maybe take kind of
keep your opponent guessing here maybe
there's a take maybe there's a jab at
the bishop bishop here
and then complete your development yep
you got a got a shield this fun maybe do
this one or two that might have been a
mouse lip I don't know how do you
complete development now a little bit
uncomfortable sure can't castle
and that's how you're gonna do it okay
secure f5 we don't want to see you
Knight to f5 now there's a square for
the knight pick up a pawn okay
Knight takes Queen takes Queen takes
pawn pressure on e3 now taking out
another pawn the King is gonna run over
here and now this is excellent for black
far as I could tell things can change in
a blink but the black pieces seem to be
finding excellent squares and knight on
e3 or rook on e3 or a bishop on e3 a lot
of good things on e3 tonight is falling
with check or maybe the bishop falls
white resigns black pieces found
wonderful squares the Queen at any
moment could have entered if the night
is gone how are things changing 175 122
110 11 minutes to go in this tournament
top 5 get some money
it still seems like it could be any one
of these players on the top page here
number nine currently is Caruana which
just goes to show how strong this field
is this is incredible
John look the camera is in 10th yeah ok
let's have a look at how about penguin
versus Arkin umber two versus number
four there's too many games too many
good games to choose really 71 apiece is
their match score let's see how this one
finishes up I guess this was from some
looks like a Benoni structure
body counts up the exchange white is up
the exchange here you could scoop this
guy up just some simplification yeah
black is resigning these guys are
pushing to connected passers and I are
writing
1:26 1:12 he's definitely pulling away
nope
okay let's stay right here Carlson
versus the penguin let's do it and we
have this g4 again so we watched it from
penguins perspective the last time
Carlson did this and it's happening
again let's see how penguin changes
things up here I might have to try this
g4 stuff against the penguin
then blunder my queen later okay oh he
just wants to Bishop exchange and then
the knight here that's all he wants just
just use the word just because it's so
easy this night has been sidelined the
white pieces have wonderful squares
there's no great way to challenge this
pawn now pressure here oh that's nice
the old clearance discovered attack
Bishop takes Bishop pac-man mount takes
the Queen with the fork around that
hurts look at the clock
39 seconds to 19 yeah
this one's not gonna end good for the
penguin yeah he resigned okay I I
understand why you resigned that was a
wonderful shot d6 brutal
all right opera let's see what opera has
number three trying to close the gap
between himself and penguin let's see if
he could pull backs come back into
second place land
even-steven yeah even material a white
rooks will get active hmm you're ready
to play f5 now yeah this is
uncomfortable f7 is collapsing there's
no defense now bishop g6 f5 and now we
have the rooks crashing through on g7
next and that bishops now cut off he's
he's like over here and the action is on
these squares and he can now help
control any of these squares how do you
control this there's no defense so you
got this this and probably I resign here
there's just some silly checks but
there's nothing
anything else okay tell you what the
rest of this tournament and I make it
really simple well hang on that's hang
on for a second I think as much as I
want to check out Carlson Opera has a
chance to take over
he is only eight points behind penguin
this is a huge game right here
number three versus number two this
could this is this is a huge game this
is potentially a battle for the second
place prize right here this game with
six minutes and change to go
I don't like blacks position though the
timing was not right for this advance
Penguins gonna be able to play b5
because of this pin and there's gonna as
a result there's gonna be some weakness
that the penguin will be able to bite
out on the Queen side although there is
now an opportunity for the rook to move
and so b5 won't be able to be played
rook here and you have to be a little
bit careful of this idea now
and isn't this winning a piece now I
thought black needed to move the moved
upon so that the night out a new square
but this is still here penguin did this
in the first yeah he just resigned this
is hitting ins
who's gonna be down a piece so under six
minutes to go here the standings 187 130
120 yeah that might have just done it
that was a huge huge game right there
let's have a look at Carlson Carlson
versus Minear number one versus number
ten
you know probably kicking himself some
over that game is a tough one
um yeah initially I thought got even a
little bit lucky that he was able to get
off of the a file in that game so that
b5 couldn't hit but then fell so fell
into that little tactic with h3 and g4
oh okay that one just happened way too
fast okay
Carlson versus ARCA Scandinavian is
being thrown at Carlson let's see how he
handles the Scandinavian okay some Tempe
against the bishop plant the knight on
e5 Bishop pair for Team white breaking
in the center immediately can expect a
queenside castle at some point now the D
files gonna be open up Queen d3
queenside castle isolated pawn on c6 at
any point this night can be dislodged
although it does have a pretty good
square here okay Bishop's are killers
Bishop takes pawn where's the main is
there any Knight b5 look at how fast
these moves are this is this is so
ridiculous to see that there's a way out
of this this little rook move and both
bishops being under fire white resigned
look at these white pieces that's a 22
mover
2970 rating by the way to catch that
Carlson's rating is twenty nine seventy
okay
and now he is paired up with the number
15 guy
2976 caro-kann by carlson this bishop is
gonna get trapped what's his plan here
he he fumbled Carlson fumble that's okay
that's alright I I don't know I just
feel like he's able to come back from
anything somehow okay he has a draw is
he gonna take the draw
he's taking the drop draw I see okay
there's only three minutes to go
let's watch the penguin I think
everything's going to
I think the top five are gonna stay put
so let's just check out this game and I
guess one more so these guys are playing
the scotch for four nights for a night's
game Scotch opening the warning number
seven just out of money land
okay that was a quick resign that's a
that's a piece
okay I guess the final two games here
we're just going to stay locked in with
Carlson he's paired up again against
Arco and ARCA just resigned okay here we
go okay
this is one of the last games there's
only two minutes left
Karlsson versus penguin
I've played this line against penguin
before I might have even scored a win
against him one of the rare wins
all-righty queenside castle i imagine
this is a queenside castle game and
there we go so how all the pieces are
just playing
you say how do you how do you untangle
Bishop check and then here yeah Bishop
Bishop takes fun there's a check and
then this prying it open
can blackett castled look at the
centralization all the pieces on
beautiful squares 30 seconds
it's fun can probably there's some
sacrifice night move there's a queen
exchange 33 seconds one minute left to
go in the tournament yeah we are going
to have the Queen's exchange huh
there's no there's still this pressure
you can't really get out of this pin and
there's Knight takes pawn here as well
up the exchange Carlson's up the
exchange 43 seconds to go let's see the
conversion he's in a pickle but the King
on a light square exchange the rook
that's the plan up material get rid of a
rook in you're golden
this Bishop is annoying though he has a
good square less than 10 seconds to 14
seconds final seconds of this tournament
15 to go he's gonna be able to mop up
some pawns
there goes the rook and there goes the
pond and that's going to do it three to
one on the tournament clock and let's
just see this one finish up
no stalemates and black just resigned
there with less than a second to go this
was a blazing fast tournament two hours
of bullet chests and there we come what
the final standings this is an
incredible performance by Carlson 199
let's see what you guys can see in the
stream here I'm just kind of scroll up a
little bit
final standings 199 Carlson takes first
$1,000 penguin takes second 250 dollars
opera is in there for third 125 dollars
ARCA 75 mud Pro 50 bucks did you catch
this 299 Erik Sumi 29 94 performance
rating by Carlson 85% win rate I said
there was about you get about 65 games
in top 3 players Carlson with 68 penguin
with 57 opera with 68
Wow 181 entered let's see all the pages
with this one just again just to
highlight how difficult this tournament
is how strong it is John let Vic hammers
and six page one Caruana isn't even on
page one where did car wanna finish car
wanna finished 16th
very very difficult that and that says
it all right there he finished second in
the first one page three
astana chess I see little peasant
Alejandro Ramirez finishing 27th nirvana
Anouar Geum on the site finishing 23rd
Eric Rosen I see 33rd let's go through
all of them Gannicus beep beep I'm a
Jeep joined late finishing 46th
Kings crusher in there at 50th I was
saying how difficult it is to get force
okay aside from this late join see a lot
of force butts
tough to pick up a form just a handful
of fours stuck it's tough to stay on
streak okay
and I think right around this point I
don't know if everybody is that we're
seeing here and actually you can't see
all the pages on the stream but yeah and
actually you weren't able to see Casey
when I was pointing out he was in 50th
he was cut off from the stream
yeah
a beefy crew of GM's AIIMS FM's NMS
seems wim s all titled course Wow
I'm I already have like that the itch to
play some bullet myself I'm not going to
do that but uh this is a what what a fun
tournament I'm looking forward to
competing in the next one
you